à l'aéroport de lille-lesquin ce matin
la catastrophe a vraiment été évité de
justesse un airbus d'air inter a percuté
un petit avion de tourisme miracle aucun
blessé patrick esther 11h15 ce matin
l'airbus a320 d'air inter en provenance
de paris orly et dans la proche finale
pour atterrir à lille le pilote vient
d'obtenir l'autorisation de la tour de
contrôle
ce qu'il ne sait pas c'est qu'au sol un
petit avion privé s'engage au même
instant sur la piste pour décoller le
brouillard couvre l'aéroport et l'airbus
se pose en mode automatique
il percute l'appareil et le fait
littéralement éclater le train
d'atterrissage avant se casse le nez de
l'airbus mord la poussière les 142
passagers et membres d'équipage sont
évacués d'urgence par les toboggans
gonflables un miracle il n'y aura pas un
seul blessé c'est un miracle aussi pour
le pilote de cet avion lors des qui se
trouvait au milieu de la piste puisque
lui-même avec un avion complètement
scalper si vous voulez eh bien il n'a
pas non plus n'est gratuit à la
responsabilité de l'accident incombait
au pilote du petit avion qui aurait pris
la piste sans en avoir l'autorisation
une faute qu'il a déjà payé une belle
frayeur